we're about to catch up on the nintendo
direct that aired this morning i missed
it
um because it was too early for me they
always saw
and then avoided news about it
absolutely all day
the only thing that i think that i've
seen is zelda related so
i was really hoping that we'd see breath
of the wild too in this um but i as soon
as i was like oh that looks like zelda
i very quickly like looked away so i
don't actually have any info about what
it is i'm hoping there's a zelda release
date
otherwise i don't know about anything in
this direct so let's watch it let's see
what's in here i'm excited um i always
love watching a nintendo direct so i'm
always always down
thank you falco thank you everybody for
watching sorry that i didn't i didn't do
it on time
it is what it is works a priority um
okay let's go
or not
maybe it it maybe it's wrong
it is wrong
how strange so when you scrub through
it looks like the starting screen's at
the end but it's actually at the start
oh skip to 29.35 okay
i just feel like i'm trying to avoid
looking at it because it looks like it
has spoilers in it okay here we go
i mean it does because it's giving me
like highlights of things
tune in for a nintendo direct live
stream at roughly that is roughly 40
minutes
okay i appreciate you telling me that
nintendo thank you
come on here
much better
we live on the continent of elios
four realms surrounding the holy land at
its center
[Music]
a thousand years ago
we called upon heroes from other worlds
to aid us heroes known as emblems
with them the fires of our nations
fought as one
in the end we were victorious in
defeating an imprisonment
in the years since our world has been
safe
but now
i sense a resurrection
the binding weakens
you kind of cute all right i'm all right
with
it blue eyes white dragon
[Music]
the fire emblem games are very good
[Music]
i wonder why it's not more popular
like it's obviously very popular
but what prevents fire emblem from
getting into that extra tier
like a final fantasy
video's too loud
okay
you're awake there you go that should be
better you're really awake yeah a
thousand years i think so that's how
long i've been asleep i'm gonna go there
tell me if that's okay
if i may
you are a divine dragon
a member of a royal family of dragons
revered as deities the war
the fel dragon
that's cool
i've had my eye on you
the ring
marth right
leave it to me
big fan of all this mountain combat
the time has come
now as one
emblem
engage
[Music]
okay this looks sick
this looks very good
please grant me your strengths this is a
pretty lengthy trailer
asked me to gather all of the rings
there are so many things here that look
like completely different video games
that like just straight up don't look
like the same game
i love that
fire emblem engage no release date
there you go
i'll take it
hello everyone hello
i'm yoshiaki koizumi and i'll be your
guide for today's nintendo ds appreciate
that thank you here to have a good time
what you just saw was the latest
installment of the fire emblem series it
looks good air emblem engage
in addition to the standard version
we'll also be releasing the fire emblem
engage divine edition containing
collectible items
beautiful
big fans look forward to more
information about this game in the
future
i will thank you
let's take a look at our first batch of
headlines
it takes two to tango
cody and may's relationship is on the
rocks
it's uh i don't know if this game's
already on switch
i'm assuming it's not when they're
turned into dolls represent extra to get
their bodies back they'll brave an
onslaught of challenges where working
together is the only way forward
team up and cooperate with a friend in
this critically acclaimed two-player
platforming adventure
such a good game this road can be
traveled
by your side
venture through fantastical worlds
filled with challenging experiences
around every corner like honestly it's
unbelievable in addition to single
system play the game can also be played
on two systems via local wireless or
online i was impressed by the single
systems
that's cool can you do that on pc i
don't know turn to noise you can because
you can always use partner of course i
just have a try
it takes two launches on the nintendo
switch system november 4th
oh okay so the tatango was just that
fancy headline thing i misunderstood
that
it's a great game it's a great game
impeccable design like unbelievably good
design
where's she got a camera
video frame fatal frame
it is fatal frame isn't it i think we
might have seen this before
yeah
baby yeah such a good series i'm already
very interested in great direct stuff
for lost memories
[Music]
use the camera obscura to repel evil
spirits and uncover the memories
ancient rituals will be revealed fatal
frames so scary mask of the lunar
eclipse back in the day i don't know if
i would now
switch next um but yes stoked to be able
to finally play
i think that games have a hero
introducing wave 2 of the xenoblade
chronicles 3 expansion pass for the
xenoblade chronicles 3 game
this is eno a new hero she appears to be
uh mechanical
complete her quest to have what does she
need to drink for
expanding your options for classes and
battle
strategies also i'm going to be honest
she doesn't look mechanical she just
looks like she's wearing a suit
test your medal in consecutive battles
against tough enemies
defeat all enemy waves to earn
rewards challenge even stronger enemies
to earn valuable accessories and special
outfits
more hero and gameplay additions will
arrive in wave three
they've been doing a great job i don't
play chronicles
they're doing a very good job of
updating
we're consistently rolling out updates
get drawn into these nintendo switch
games
nautical nonsense begins when spongebob
and patrick make a wish that unravels
the very fabric of the universe
patrick
let's go portals to seven outlandish
wish worlds look at him historic kelp
forest and wild oh my god fish fields
explore using all sorts of wacky moves
don over 30 fantastic cosmic costumes
and meet your favorite bikini bottom
residents from the small patrick contest
by their original actors that's it soak
up spongebob squarepants the cosmic
shake launching on nintendo switch next
year that game could actually be super
fun if i'm being perfectly honest
you're all ready
always love 3d platformers box with
familiar characters from fist of the
north star they'll be your instructors
in action it's a boxing game leading you
through various boxing drills defeat as
many enemies as you can with just your
fists in battle mode yo i'm so on board
in boss battles including jaggi i
sometimes i forget that the switch can
do [ __ ] like this
yeah other consoles
like you physically box frog
always down for more fitness games are
you joking
yes dude
embrace the absurdity of frantic
minigame i'm absolutely playing that
what the [ __ ] arenas customize your
character i was just thinking tonight i
was like i'm not going to play some
thrill of the fight that was going to be
my oculus workout today
i love it what the [ __ ]
oddballers launches on nintendo switch
early next year
a small fox washes ashore i love tunic i
still haven't finished it i really need
to get back to it stupid crocodiles
your only clue here is the manual
traverse the island's connected realms
to retrieve its missing pages
dangerous traps and even more dangerous
monsters lurk around definitely like one
of my game of the year contenders i love
it
what long-lost secrets will the island
reveal
tunic launches on the nintendo switch
system september 27th pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop
new intel has arrived for these front
mission remakes
full remix of two
[Laughter]
in tactical turn-based combat
as you progress you'll obtain skills
that can help you gain the upper hand
against opponents
you can also test your medal at the
coliseum
continue the battle in this sequel i
love them
released outside of japan take advantage
of additional features
weapon and armor attributes and over 80
new skills added from the first game and
this doesn't feel like one remix
launches on nintendo switch
but it could be mission two remake we'll
launch i really like that defense for
this year and i was really enjoying st
battle alliance mission three will also
launch on nintendo switch
similar vibes
it's a wonderful life for a new
generation
after nearly 20 years gotta get your
farming sims in experience is reborn
welcome back to forgotten valley it
looks very you'll manage a farm passed
down to you by your father
restore and expand your farm i like
seeing a farming city in this aspect
care for your friendly animals and help
the life flourish
it's going to say aspect ratio but it's
obviously not the right phrase
the town spoke while you're out and
about in the valley you're getting a
camera position
future partner and start a family
no
in this installment those around you
will grow older as time goes on this
looks really cute their appearances will
change over the years
your child will also choose their career
based on how you raise them
did my parents do that i guess yeah
an especially wonderful farmland one of
my biggest uh gaming sins
is that i don't like starbucky valley
i wish i could story of season it feels
like a cry wonderful life launches on
nintendo switch not that i think it's
bad i just never
got into that kind of game it's just not
for me unfortunately i wish everyone i
know who plays it loves it and i
recognize that it's good
it's just not for me i just like
fighting [ __ ] too much you know what i'm
saying
[Music]
it's harvest moon but they can't call it
harvest moon is it harvest moon debt
this is what we say
the first post-launch splatfest for
splatoon 3 has been confirmed
here's the theme
what would you bring to a deserted
island gear grub or fun okay okay
we've come a long way from uh
ketchup of mustard
so many incredible possibilities nice
which team nice thing
and more free updates are planned for
splatoon 3.
it's literally office mood
i'm not sure what you mean by that i'll
look it up later
is it wasn't it not cold harvest moon
so squids
what did you think
what would you bring to a deserted
island
i mean grub egg food for me no i've
already decided no it should be geared i
hope you'll all participate
because then you can get more up
next please take a look at this
why didn't they go give food or fun
you've seen this it's very very very
very pretty
introducing a brand new game in the
octopath travelers
haven't we seen this before the set the
octopus traveler was in october traveler
2 already now it's on a journey through
the land of celestia i really enjoyed it
god i think that was the first game i
ever streamed i'm going on youtube
actually and bring smiles to people's
faces was octopus
i'm hitting the road i'll be back once i
eliminate that i really really enjoyed
it
the man who took everything but i love
her rpg the japan
as it were not again not this stench the
stench of blood
doubt is what i do
leave the hunting to me you'll have all
the tasty meat you want
i need to rediscover who i am
explore a wide world sad enough so
pretty
the odds beautiful each traveler's path
action differs between day and night
i'm a big fan of the like
focal points of the camera as well
so pretty
and what adventures await them in this
new world
we haven't seen it before i'm not
thinking of live alive that's a very
different game
it's possible
i knew the game existed was it just
announced i definitely knew it existed
launches on nintendo switch it is
please look forward to the journeys of
eight new heroes
let's see some more headlines thank you
look at ah
i feel like video game conferences have
finally learned how to pace things well
it's great go home is waiting for you
welcome to your new i've never heard of
triangle strategy so i don't know what
that is
cultivating i'm telling me i've heard of
something that i've never even known and
forged everlasting friendships in this
farm simulation
rpg discover magical spells to grow
crops
face off against mischievous foes
and explore the enchanted realms of
azoria
along the way you'll befriend a lively
cast of characters who call this island
their home tend and grow your fairy tale
farmstead so this is bomb game number
two up to four players in local or
online multiplayer i wonder if some of
this is spawned by
crafting items the insane success of
animal crossing enjoy this mesmerizing
adventure even more that's why there's
such a focus on it two years later new
spellbinding suppression for a deaf
cycle
that'll help you restore even if i've
reacted to it in a conference i don't
remember it i promise
magic
no idea what fake triangle what did you
call it exclusively on nintendo switch
spring 2020 i don't know what it was
even called
it's a musical blast from the past okay
celebrate the 35th anniversary of the
final fantasy series with the latest
theater rhythm game
enjoy iconic songs like one winged angel
it is one of my favorite songs
suteki danae and more
there are 385 songs total
songs are categorized by game so you can
play
haters the way they look through the
music
i hate
why are you going to see my boy be like
that quickly can complete stages i hate
styles i hate those players
oh my god online
something about it makes me think of
like begins its symphony on the nintendo
switch system that's very cool
but that that shitty ad that you get on
mobile where it's like the guy trying to
escape from the river dlc songs from the
saga series
no near series
okay well i love that that's some good
music and that's yours octopath traveler
live alive and more will be released
that's 90 additional songs
plus additions containing a season pass
and 27 extra songs including melodies of
life will be never played any of the
series before i'm sure it's very cool
but wow i hate that hostile
[Music]
a cosmic adventure is just around the
corner
blast off on an adventure of galactic
proportions
looks very good from everything i've
seen dive into exploration
freely roam through all sorts of wonders
surprisingly very good
with discoveries
not that the first one wasn't good i
just mean like
find coins
unlock hidden paths
it just looks like a banger help out the
locals with their troubles
[Music]
at shops you can get items that'll come
in handy during battles after each quest
or battle your team will earn rewards
and get stronger sparks are here to land
a helping hand recruit up to 30
different sparks each with their own i
love like like how much they've they can
help change things a decisive victory
like it's just a very good
follow-up
can mario and the rabbits put an end
doesn't look like a whole new game but
it's like a very clear expansion
improvement sparks of hope launches on
the previous game i really think that's
game gonna be very good these are
available now on nintendo eshop
a gold edition can also be pre-ordered
it is like xbox yeah if you haven't
played them with characters
season pass
[Music]
restore peace between humans and
monsters
roon factory three returns on nintendo
switch
that frame rate was something break from
quest to chat with the locals cultivate
crops oh another one monsters okay
i see i see i see the trend i'm seeing
see what's going down
[Laughter]
to a monster
your abilities that's not a monster
that's like a little sheep with a hat
depending on your form come on now
choices
little butt it's a rat what is it
trending it's a monster
enjoy more quality time with your
in-game spouse
roon factory 3 special launches on
nintendo switch next year it's a pretty
uh
logo
dramatic plus a new roon factory series
will launch in the future
more nintendo 64 games are on the way
pilot wings you speak my language
superman 64.
yes
the first one mario party 2. oh the best
one is the second one let's go
let's get
clearly the second one
pokemon stadium
thank you pokemon stadium 2. also less
good but still good
[Music]
1080 snowboarders
64.
never played exactly these games will
gradually be added in the future yes
dude mario party 2 forever games and
enjoy many more gaming benefits with an
accidental switch online plus expansion
still have my 64.
it's downstairs one more game we should
mention
oh [ __ ] it's happening goldeneye
about time
[Music]
oh my god yeah please
yes
online play please
oh my god i can't wait to like organize
streams for that catch games it's gonna
be so fun live your best life on the
newly discovered continent of antoisia
in this immersive rpg i'm very excited
i'm just really excited man
to build character and deepen your
relationships that's good it's going to
be so fun to get a big group and play it
online oh my god classes and abilities
we knew that was coming for a while
right is it only on switch i figured
that would also be on other platforms
various daylight launches on nintendo
switch later today
i'm sorry
a malfunction causes you to crash land
on a strange planet i try not to pause
these because of the because i'm doing
it live right um
various day life
and it's in that same font square enix
always uses
is everything okay
naming video games is hot it's a
difficult thing to do it's a challenge
maybe that was the translation problem
various day life okay it's fine it's my
factorio you rock it on the other hand
management sim game
scour the planet for materials it is a
really good game then build machines to
refine them into various resources don't
let the
graphics put you off
multiple it is very very good
but the planet's creatures will attack
so keep them at bay
factorio launches on nintendo switch
october 2 it'll actually be a really
good game to play on
switch a young girl named ib visits an
art museum with their parents in this 2d
yeah various daylife and triangle
strategies
until
one particular piece draws her in
will she be able to safely return to her
own world
every decision affects her fate in ib
launching on nintendo switch spring
2023.
whoa what a unique
mario strike style that has players
locally on one system
dazzling techniques and high pass
accuracy
[Music]
plus more gear and another stadium are
being added
the second free update launches this
month the final summer this looks like
another jrpg we better have
farming strange islands suddenly appear
riza and friends set sail to investigate
in order to protect their homeland
sprawling landscapes set the stage for
your adventure
freely explore this vast world excuse
you in heels
in this charming rpg
11 heroes from all walks of life will
join your party what the heck
during battle work with your allies to
which can be swapped out when needed
teamwork is paramount after all
[Music]
new features are also in store
the keys to this lively adventure are in
your hands
atelier rise of three alchemist of the
end and the secret key launches on the
nintendo switch system february 24th i
would like to see the dolphin again
please
[Music]
like to see more of the dolphin
wave three is on the way
do you think they'll ever make any mario
kart there's a sneak peek at two courses
racing into wave three they don't need
to i guess it's so good tour
[Music]
that's my best yoshi impression
peach gardens from mario kart ds
banger of course to be honest
[Music]
wave three of the mario kart 8 deluxe
booster course pass dlc for the mario
kart 8 deluxe game launches this holiday
active nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack members can enjoy this
dlc at no additional cost the dlc can
also be purchased on its own
[Music]
how was that
great thank you we have some news to
share about nintendo switch sports
needs a lot more games man update golf
it just it was so limited
of course you can play these locally
additionally up to eight players online
can play at the same time on the same
course in survival golf
those with the most strokes will be out
we previously announced that the update
would release this fall however we'd
like a bit more time for development so
the update is now planned for this
holiday i way preferred that just a
little longer to announce a delay
next we have a special guest then
mr miyamoto the twitter image
hello it's been a while i'm shigeru
miyamoto
i have a few things i'd like to share
with you today including some news
first as you may have heard
the super mario brothers animated movie
we're developing with chris melidandry
from illumination will release next
spring
super nintendo world which is entering
its second year at universal studios
japan they're excited about been in
hollywood california in the us
recently we've been working on the
finishing touches for both oh my god i
can't wait it's gonna be so cool today
i'd like to talk a little bit about
pikmin
it's been over 20 years since the first
game and we're still working on the
series
this is pikmin bloom it's been 20 years
since the last pick started with niantic
late last year in which players all over
the world are planting flowers
here's a quick rundown of the game for
those who have yet to play it
pikmin bloom is a smart device game that
uses your location
by walking outside you can find pikmin
raise them and plant flowers together
it's actually a pretty good idea
all you need to do is take it with you
on your daily walks or outings
you can look back at the end of the day
and see where you walked
send out pikmin and collect the items
they found that day
and since the first pikmin that makes a
lot more sense i was like there have
been other pigments since
in the last 20 years did we take today
obviously this
while you're out and about you can also
use the ar feature to take photos with
pikmin
that's very cute pikmin are all around
you
let's take a quick look at my screen
i have nearly 700 pikmin that's too many
they love nectar you've got to get rid
of those things if you give pikmi nectar
like you see here so you ever run
you'll also see the number of steps
you've taken that day
regarding the map the clouds will clear
along the path you walk so you can keep
a record of locations you've visited
i know this is an infestation so you
need you need to call going to osaka to
universal studios japan insect control
i occasionally go to tokyo as well also
you doxing yourself okay this time i'll
try walking here it makes trips and
walks a lot of fun
it's a very easy going thank you for
letting me know everywhere you go just
by t-shirt huge fan i hope you'll try it
out
okay now to the main event please take a
look at this
zelda
celta
no it's still going to be pikmin
this ain't no
zelda this is more pikmin main event
you mentioned if it was
breath of the wild too
[Music]
hey i'm happy for the pikmin fans out
there but he can't say main event
all right shigeru okay
you knew what you were doing that's
right oh [ __ ]
in 2023.
we won't be showing any gameplay today
however
you'll be able to play like this
from the pikmin's perspective near the
ground
i also made a new t-shirt
nintendo switch has made controlling the
game simpler meaning you can further
concentrate on the core essence of
pikmin gameplay we call it dandori in
japanese or strategically planning
deploying and commanding the pikmin i
hope you're all looking forward to
pikmin 4. it's intimidating mr koizumi
thank you very much mr miyamoto
now let's move on to some more headlines
okay
[Music]
take your dancing game to the next level
it's a new ubisoft dance game
[Music]
oh it's just just dance
that makes sense
that's a good idea
i reviewed the first just dance that
came out on switch for ign because i
wanted to have a switch so i could play
breath of the wild
so i agreed one two switch just dance
and another thing
because it meant that i got to keep a
switch for the week so we could play
solo
[Music]
and they're generally really fun we
actually had a group at ign who would
play
um
just dance in one of the like meeting
rooms that had a big projector screen it
was really fun
it was like every friday people would
just play just dance together
yeah i don't care about the
puppy right the season of death it's
fine it happens all the time i'm not
trying to make money out here as you
cultivate a peaceful farm life in the
village of leafy there we there we go
more farming
threatening to destroy all
travel the world and find a way to put
an end to the calamity in this life
simulation rpg
along the way allies with different
motives will join your cause i feel like
this direction facing numerous dangers
there's been stuff that i've liked in
here for sure
a bunch of this ill-fated world
it always feels like you should
presentation a demo containing too many
of the games are too similar that none
of them stand out will be available on
nintendo and it really feels like they
should like pick and choose to avoid
that problem once purchased
harvest stella launches on nintendo
switch november 4. how are they even
going to compete with each other it's
just a few too many
get ready for a devilishly good time i
would love to hello man
after 500 years umbra witch bayonetta
was revived my queen present day i love
you so much stephanie
she clashed with angels to recover her
lost memories
and in the second confronted demons to
save her best friend
now in this third installment she'll
fight to protect the world from the
sudden invasion of man-made bioweapons
called homunculi
a monkey
boss so it's every
character journey find yourself save
your best friend save the world to
fighting for others
to fighting for the world
those who have overcome their past
histories with bayonetta to fight
alongside her include the journalist
luca
and another umbra witch sean
new ally viola also joins in on the
action
a hair raising
i'm stuck in summoning
globe trotting adventure awaits
in bayonetta 3
launching a nintendo switch october 20th
that's so soon pre-orders are available
now i don't know why that made me feel
scared
but
yes let's go correct a new trailer
delving more into gameplay will launch
on our official youtube channel don't
mind if i do
a dark fantasy mystery abounds from the
creators of danganronpa
welcome to the city of perpetual rain
i like the vibe of this unsolved in this
corporate-controlled metropolis
[Music]
those who investigate are called master
detectives who come from all around okay
[Music]
into it what
meet yuma an amnesiac detective
and shinigami the spirit haunting him
after they're packed
dive into these nights she saw cases as
a trainee at the detective agency that
looked like uh i totally inspect each
question
when you're ready shinigami will conjure
a realm tying the crime scene to the
truth
a mystery labyrinth
overcome obstacles and manifestations of
mysteries to edge closer to the actual
events you had me at creators of
danganronpa mystery phantoms will
attempt to hinder your progress during
it's like got some persona vibes to it
as well their barrage of falsehoods and
slashed through contradiction dude
uncover the secrets of master detective
archives absolutely yes launching first
on the nintendo switch system spring
2023 oh that means it's not platform
exclusive
enter the village if you dare
curious how this performs
the latest installment in the resident
evil series is
ethan winters must face the horrors of
the village and its four fearsome lords
to rescue his abducted daughter
resident evil village
to pre-order the full game i would be
curious to try it
the winter's expansion dlc containing a
new third-person mode
additional story content and more will
launch december 2nd i'm very excited
about that additionally
that's too many editions resident evil
series will be available as cloud
versions on nintendo switch
this year
it's an action-packed lineup of nintendo
switch games
vanquish foes to avenge your father in
this kung fu action brawler
by thrusting
tripping and parrying opponents you'll
break their stance and gain the upper
hand that looks rough
fall in combat and you'll get older and
weaker
in turn however you'll learn new
techniques
love seafood can you exact revenge
before your time runs out
sifu pummels its way onto nintendo
switch november 8th pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop
it's just if you show the frame rate
drops in the trailer leading up to final
fantasy vii this is an exhilarating
action rpg yeah zach baer is a young and
ambitious soldier operative aspiring to
become a hero
together with sephiroth and cloud i have
so much fondness for that game
appearances within his elite unit
this remaster features enhanced hd
graphics i might do it you know i might
play it again and new soundtrack
arrangements
crisis core final fantasy 7 reunion
launches on nintendo switch december
13th
it's hard to get me to play games i've
played before because i'm like but i
have new stuff to play but oh i love
crisis core fire different types of
weapons to take down waves of enemies
defeat multiple enemies of the same
color for a chain bonus
or take down differently colored ones
for a secret bonus
rack up these bonuses for a high score
rack up these bonuses radiant silver gun
launches on nintendo switch later today
recruit a team of shipwrecked heroes and
make your way out of a derelict space
station in this rogue-like game set in
the endless universe
but it's not as easy as it sounds
you'll have to fend off continuous waves
of monsters as you make your way through
procedurally generated levels complete
various quests to unlock new heroes
weapons station areas and more
up to three players in online co-op can
attempt to escape their grim fate
do you have what it takes
endless dungeon launches
next year
the journey of world regeneration begins
anew
that sentence is not the master of tales
of symphonia is coming to nintendo
switch
the world of silverant is controlled by
shadowy forces called the science to
stop them a person known as the chosen
one must ascend
[Music]
lloyd soon embarks on a journey with
colette the current chosen one and his
childhood friend in this beloved action
rpg
they'll meet allies along the way
like the wandering aristocrat zellos
and a lumberjack who lost her emotions
after an experiment presea
other allies will also join the party
[Music]
the fate of two interconnected worlds
hangs in the balance
tales of symphonia remastered also never
played
this is a lot of video games
the video games just keep coming
and i feel like this conference makes
sense for tgs
it suits
tokyo game show a lot of jrpgs
[Music]
what's my boy up to
hello son kirby's return to dreamland
deluxe is coming to nintendo switch i
just love you so much
one day a spaceship crash lands on
planet pop star
to help magalor return to his home
planet we don't deserve kirby we just
don't
know
in addition to sword
whip
and other familiar abilities
makes its debut
blast foes from a distance or punch him
up close yeah you tell him cubby it's
packed
the game supports local play for up to
four players on the same system
plus everyone can play as kirby while
using their favorite copy abilities
there's also a collection of sub games
to play
that includes the new sub game
magalore's tome trackers
and returning ones like samurai kirby
very good very good all sub games can be
played with up to four players
barrio mario party
[Music]
an adventure of deluxe proportions
awaits
kirby's return to dreamland deluxe
launches on the nintendo switch system
february 24th 2023. pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop very cute
as part of kirby's 30th anniversary a
remake of kirby's return to dreamland
will be released
we hope you're looking forward to this
game thank you
thank you for watching today's nintendo
direct
i'm so sure they sold it this next
trailer will be our last announcement
please take a look
let's go
there it is hello
i don't know what to take from this
just try to be very quiet
thank you i was like is it just gonna be
pretty odd
that i'm sure i can read into later
[Music]
damn
you got all vertical
oh
that's cool
[Music]
oh my god i love it
that that's such a good idea
tears of the kingdom it's not called
breath of the wild too
i imagine it's a sequel but
it's not like they've ever done that
anyway majora's mask is an awkward
enough time too
yo that's a really good idea oh my gosh
let's go i assume that that means
december
because it's a japanese conference
right
it's not american
no but this is 9 13.
so is it may
it's me
oh my brain
[Laughter]
i don't know the stupid international
dates
um
yes good
i'll watch a breakdown of that so
somebody can
over explain to me what all the
symbology means i'm very into it
i enjoyed this direct i think
like i said probably a few too many
very
similar
video games
um
which makes none of them stand out by
virtue of them all being like oh well
this is like that last one oh this is
like that oh this is like that lost one
which is unfortunate i kind of wish they
would figure out a way to space those
out it seems odd that nobody's
considering that but
otherwise
i really enjoyed it
um
it was fun some stuff i'm very
interested in some stuff i'm not at all
which is always the case and i'm always
okay with that i think
uh weren't like a ton of huge
announcements here i didn't feel like
but
that i don't care it's games i'm
interested in you know it's always just
fun to watch a conference i feel like
like people have gotten so toxic about
them where i've always ever since i was
a kid and i was waking up at 3am in
australia
i've always just like watched them like
they're a show not like um
something i'm paying to watch you know
i would agree that there is something
for everyone for sure
too many third-party games nintendo
content made like less than 20 webs in
it yeah but that just happens sometimes
like
it being tgs i think that that
makes sense uh maybe not
um
but i don't see why that's a problem i
don't know i'm right with it there's
stuff that i would have liked to have
seen that wasn't there but definitely
some like big standouts for me for sure
um
yeah i enjoyed it
not not completely blown away
but uh there was stuff there that like i
was immediately sold on so that's always
fun almost too many games to be honest
like more than i think i can
handle
which like makes me go oh too many good
games oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um all right it is now almost 2 a.m so
i'm gonna end this i'll check out that
bayonetta trailer at some point um
the gameplay for that because i'm a big
fan
but that is gonna be it for me everybody
thank you for watching i don't think
there are any more conferences i was
going to stream this week i was thinking
about doing on thursday morning that
i think was yakuza
i don't remember capcom it was capcom um
but i'll probably do a reaction to it
afterwards just because the 7am which is
my body can't handle it